right now I do not feel safe on campus
I'm still proud you I wear my Star of
David every day I am proud I'm proud of
my Heritage I don't feel safe on campus
right now a lot of my friends are in the
IDF a lot of my family is in Israel my
cousins are there right now my like so
many of my friends um I taught in a
youth Village there um for a few Summers
and my friends from the youth Village
are currently in the Army the youth
Village is being underfunded the I'm
just so worried for the safety of my
people for my friends there and I feel
like I should be there fighting right
now Palestine stands in full solidarity
with Palestinians as they resist over 75
years of Israeli s colonialism and AP uh
this is a protest uh to celebrate the
quote historic win unquote um of Hamas
uh in Israel over the weekend frankly
looking at this it's disgusting
resistance is Justified when people are
occupied I I was overwhelmed by by how
many people came out to to support what
I think is just terrible it's brutality
it's Massacre of um of innocent
civilians and it should be strongly
condemned and instead they're here
celebrating this and I had people walk
in front of me try to trip me I think it
was a very peaceful protest and yeah it
was good I feel like this shouldn't be
allowed I mean I'm all for Palestinians
being free but like the timing of this
is just really like why now why after
ter they they said at the beginning of
this protest they said that our people
broke down the barrier everyone sheared
the terrorists got into Israel killed a
thousand people is that what they're
celebrating
what did you expect would happen when
you Bes H for almost decades a bunch of
brainwashed individuals who um just
don't have no idea what's going on right
now in Israel both in Palestine and
they're just
misinformed uh they don't understand the
terror that Hamas is causing to the
Israeli citizens good energy a lot of
people came to support some people came
to try and make a scene but we kept calm
and everything went well I find this
protest incredibly incredibly
disrespectful to the loss of life
thousands of Jews dead the most amount
of Jews dead since the Holocaust people
who don't think this is a second
Holocaust are ignorant and they need to
educate themselves this whole thing they
are supporting a terrorist organization
they are not supporting Palestinians who
want peace with Israel they are
supporting a dee rooted hate of Jews so
when they say from The River To The Sea
they want to wipe Israel entirely they
don't believe in a two-state solution
they don't believe that Israel has the
right to
exist